[Musik]
mai zu sagen wir machen heute eine neue
folge wie vom bäcker es gibt ja schon
einige rezepte bei denen ich dinge nach
macht die dann so schmecken wie vom
bäcker also so die klassiker kann ich
euch meine playlist hier unten verlinken
und wir machen heute käsebrötchen wie
vom wecker die könnte zum frühstück
schmecken mit in die unternehmen die
schule mit zur arbeit oder einfach vor
ihr bock drauf will morgen ich auch
käsebrötchen voll mein ding meine mutter
hat mir immer käse brötchen gekauft wenn
es nicht geschafft hat mir ein brot
zwischen hirn und wenn sie brot
geschmiert hat dann gab's immer
frischkäse aber es müsste mal gemacht
habe ich wollte das auch so über diese
kruste bekommt ja sie hallo ich kurz das
beste weil direkt ganz genau wenn ich
einen unten in der video beschreibung
ich starte jetzt direkt ich habe hier
ganz normales mädel typ 405 da gebe ich
jetzt salz rein
ich gebe auch zucker das zucker hilft
auch noch einmal den geschmack umrundet
das ganze schon ab 40 wundert warum da
nehme ich heute trockenhefe ihr könntet
auch frische hierfür nehmen falls ihr
frische hefe benutzt dann müsst ihr das
vorab mit dem lauwarmen wasser fahren
ich muss das jetzt nicht in meinen tag
kommen dass die trockenen zutaten ein
bisschen verrühren mit dem schneebesen
und mache ich mit den händen weiter ich
würde auch extra nicht die
küchenmaschine damit leuten die keine
küchenmaschine da haben sehen wie
einfach das geht so jetzt habe ich hier
lauwarmes wasser dann gebe ich das öl
dazu und dann wird verknetet
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich den teig 45 minuten lang
mit den händen erst in eine schüssel
dann auf der arbeitsfläche durchgeknetet
und ihr merkt auch der ist mega
geschmeidig der klebt überhaupt nicht
ich form ihn jetzt so halbwegs zu einer
kugel und dann gehe ich ihn zurück in
die schüssel
die werde ich jetzt ein bisschen
vettweiß jetzt einfach nicht noch mehr
möchte damit der teig auch geschmeidig
bleibt nicht austrocknet ich nehme jetzt
jemand back spray oben auf die
oberfläche das ist sogar noch wichtiger
so erleben jetzt zugedeckt 45 minuten
lang ruhen lassen der teig sollte dann
schön aufgehen und dann geht es schon
weiter und das ist nun wirklich sehr
schnelles rezept daher wird das video
doch nicht so lange gehen bis gleich
[Musik]
so nach der brutzeit nehmen wir uns den
teig auf die arbeitsfläche und teilen
ihnen mit der tankkarte durch sechs und
dann könnt ihr es direkt auf das
backblech tun ich habe das wackelig
vorher eingefettet wichtig ist dass ihr
euren teig zu kugeln rollt und auf dem
backblech nochmal ganz leicht an drückt
und so müssen sie jetzt noch mal ruhen
die entspannung ist sehr sehr wichtig
bei dem teig damit er später auch
richtig schön gut schmeckt und häufig
wird so ist denke ich das noch mal zu
diesmal nur 15 minuten und dann
bestreite ich die teiglinge mit ei und
bestreut sie mit käse wird 30 käse
[Musik]
die käse brötchen werden jetzt im
vorgeheizten backofen bei 180 grad ober
unterhitze für ca 18 minuten gebacken
und wenn ihr sie schön weich lassen
wollte so schön weich beibehalten
möchtet dann am besten direkt in einen
stoffbeutel verpacken also hauptsache
irgendwas die luftdichte damit sie nicht
austrocknen weisen uns jetzt noch mega
mega weich und noch warm und ich mag man
erstmal außen die kruste hier ab zu
machen und zu essen und dann es ist das
ganze mädchen noch mal auf so sieht's
aus also genau so mag ich den teig schön
saftig bei mir kommt ja immer mit rein
bei käse brötchen und ich habe es mir
jetzt einfach mal schmecken das ist
tatsächlich mein mittagessen vielleicht
mache ich noch was immer mein traum wäre
für käse brötchen zu hause machen ja
käsebrötchen also ich mache hier nur
noch zuhause jahren schon meine mama
oder so und jetzt sondern und machen
richtig richtig lecker okay was jetzt
hab ich zu energie jetzt kommt noch ein
richtiges auto also ganze freude ihm
nachmachen
hinterlasst mir unbedingt ein
kostenloses abo falls es noch nicht
schon längst getan habt und bitte bitte
schreibt mir in die kommentare
welches rezept ich wie vom bäcker als
nächstes für euch nach machen soll dann
mache ich mich daran und wir lassen uns
das jetzt schmecken und da wünsche ich
euch noch einen wunderschönen tag bis
zum nächsten acht die sketche
[Musik]